thank you
[Music]
so some of you may remember your first
love How Could You Forget
you
well I remember this story
vividly
[Music]
too vividly
I was in elementary school
and there is this young boy named David
he was the cutest kid of the class of
course
so uh it was Valentine's Day
and uh I was real shy as a kid
and I told my mom about it my mom said
not that
my mom said you're gonna buy him a teddy
bear some chocolates
some flowers you're gonna tell them how
you feel
I said
absolutely not
[Music]
absolutely not
she bought it for me and sent it to
school with me
and uh I was in class
and I was like I'm gonna build up the
courage to put this on David's desk
and tell them how I feel
right
so I built up the courage I was like
okay I'm really nervous I'm gonna I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do
it okay my friend's like yeah you should
definitely do that I'm like okay I'm
gonna do it so I started writing this
letter of like the things I loved about
him and like how I felt and just how we
should be together
and so lunchtime came
and I knew where he sat
and so I went to go put all the stuff on
the chair
and I waited for him to go get it
and I saw him
pick out the chocolates look at the bear
he started reading the letter
I was like oh my God oh my God so
stressful
[Music]
and uh he started walking towards me he
was like oh my God this is this is my
moment this is my moment I'm gonna be
with David Dave is going to be with me
and uh he walked over to me and not just
him it was a group of his friends I'd
say about eight to ten people oh [ __ ]
okay
yeah so
it was intimidating I thought I was
nervous before but then seeing that I
was really scared
he took the box of chocolates he looked
at the notes he looked at me and he
threw the box of chocolates
on me everywhere
and I was just like what he goes I don't
like you
oh little [ __ ] and I was
shocked I was devastated
I looked at my friend who said
to do that and to give him the notes and
the chocolates
and she walked away with David
oh
yeah
definitely start crying
and um when I went home
I was pissed at my mom
I was like how could you make me do this
and now I have to go back to school and
see David
and Emily
[ __ ] [ __ ]
together for the rest of the year and
that's why I hate Valentine's Day
Emily is huh
[Applause]
this is the best part
of the story so in high school that guy
David found me on Facebook
added me and asked me out on a date and
I was like are you [ __ ] kidding me of
course I will
absolutely not yes absolutely not wow
crazy full circle moment how old are you
guys uh we were in elementary school was
that like 10 or something like third
grade so Emily was already with him I
was like yeah you should totally do I
don't think she was I think it was just
like uh oh that happened
um
she tried to use that situation to like
usurp okay yeah Emily the usurper
what a little [ __ ] ass Emily is huh it
was so sad Valentine's [ __ ] thrown at
you and I remember telling my mom was
like I don't want to do this I don't and
your mom prepared it for you and
everything like what's the worst that
could happen and I'm like she's like
honey they're not even that aerodynamic
they can't be thrown that far why don't
you wear this white white on white today
wear your white dress how do you look so
good chocolate stains everywhere like
Carrie wear my wedding dress
yeah it was a good Lord yo that's crazy
I remember the kids laughing oh my god
oh the kids laughing they're like huh
and that was Emily ratajowski no way wow
wow
it's sad that's a sad story but you know
I got mine in the end because I said no
to him high school when you try a loser
dude have you ever had a good
Valentine's Day after that yeah oh okay
but you still hate Valentine's Day yeah
I was just for the story
oh my god do you think it's corporate
yeah me yeah it is yes it is it
absolutely did anybody afterwards like
ever give you like chocolate and like a
letter just like by chance because
that's a very you know Valentine's
relationship would that trigger you yeah
um no because I got mine in the end the
the like the the full circle moment of
him adding me yeah Jesus Christ it's
like
did you couldn't believe it did you
super poke him yeah no he's trying to
ask his dad out or something
that is funny and it sucks chocolates at
him you know what's even worse tell his
dad try to convince his dad that he he
could have a rap crew and film the
sickest music video oh [ __ ] I was like
kids all embarrassed I got bars man like
just hype them up what was this guy's
name David so David you should have a
baby with his dad and name it David have
his dad and you love new David more than
him you did a new David systematically
destroyed Junior that's even worse he's
not even correctly a junior
he's like wait I'm already confused but
it's basically like he gets wiped from
existence yeah he never existed
um and then make sure David dates a girl
named Emily in the future yeah but I
don't want to queue with somebody who
throws chocolates or even in that
lineage I didn't know his father yes
you're right to change him right sure
yeah it could be a a genetics thing
chocolate chocolate throwing yeah gotta
get those [ __ ] out here sounds like
you dodged a bullet sounds like David
was a little [ __ ] she didn't dodge a
chocolate though that's right but then I
went back to school and I was like all
my friends were just like embarrassed
for me so they didn't want to be around
me
I was like oh it's a tough age yeah
you're gonna look back to see what
David's up to now is he a [ __ ] loser
uh he's like oh he's like oh wow you're
really doing it these days like recently
again I love that trip you're really
doing it like again these days you
should for sure I try to have sex with
that I was watching you right now
he uh I don't know I think it is like
construction or something oh good so
he'll probably watch you after work
hours
I gotta say we do need directions we do
yeah they're important I hope he falls
off a roof then
it's sad because it's like statistically
accurate it can't happen it's probably
very [ __ ] Staples his hand to a
[ __ ] two by four oh yeah it just runs
around going back like my mom was just
like damn like I forced her to do this
and now it's like this
thing just burned into my memory
you think uh this coming Valentine's day
you'll be able to uh observe it and
practice the tradition you're gonna
practice this Valentine's the
matrimonial traditions
um no I think I'm just gonna eat a box
of chocolates
cool don't uh don't go throwing it
across the room don't waste it you know
no no I'm always full it doesn't sound
like you came out on top if you're like
I'm just gonna eat a box of chocolates
alone in a room
she's winning the trash she's like
looking in the mirror throwing it at the
mirror
you're dead every year every every year
dude David has no [ __ ] hopefuls you
know he's not hitting anybody up
he's hitting people up from elementary
school and they're going over in payroll
at one of those Portables he's he's
[ __ ] got a construction job doing a
recession
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]